when the show is on when the audience is
there
there is an energy a circle of energy
that has to start from the artist on
stage
go out to you as an audience and come
back to the artists that are on the
stage
if this circle is not complete if it's
broken due to some
and it's always energy we're dealing
with music music is pure energy
if the sound is not right if the
performance is not right if the audience
is bored and i see it immediately i feel
it
wow then you have to tweak it and look
at it
as a whole welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
this episode is very very special if
you're into music
if you're into thinking about life this
episode is for you
meet gadi gido artistic director career
manager and also a good friend
ghadi was born in israel right before
they put a man on the moon he moved to
new york upon completing his three years
of mandatory military service
and graduated with a bachelor's degree
from nyu stern school of business
as well as with an mba degree from
harvard university
he had been working his entire
professional life in the music industry
assuming various roles in major record
companies currently he is enjoying his
independence as a freelance artist
manager and consultant
ghadi is married to yuki kato and is the
father of yasmin
leah and eden he is also one of the
founding fathers of the modern israeli
music industry
welcome gadi welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you for inviting me here
it's pleasure
i've done um almost 500 episodes now
this i've been waiting for i
i you know it's hard to explain why but
you know i'm sitting here with somebody
that you know you you the work that
you've done has brought so much joy into
my life
and millions of lives whether they know
it or not
and you're also a lot of times backstage
right i i make it a rule to be backstage
always figuratively but also physically
practically absolutely yes i believe
my job is to put the artist first in the
front
and make the most out of them right
those who have to be in the shadows
should remain
there so i'm going to put you in the
front for just a little bit now because
i i
have to give him i'm going to try i'm
going to try and behave normally yep
the context here is important because
i'm sitting next to somebody
nyu harvard coming back working with
some of the most incredible artists
in israel from idaho to illinois
eurovision and it's
really shaping the israeli music
industry
with insights that i can't wait to get
to here
and i want you to take me back a little
bit it's it's not trivial getting to
work to where you got to
and having the unique experiences that
you've had
tell me a little bit about that um
immediately upon being released from the
idea
from the israeli army i found myself
flying to the big apple new york
i was a musician from the age of three i
think the first thing i ever said
uh was that i won a guitar and my hands
were too short so
it took a while a few years to find a
private tutor who would be able to teach
me how to play
but that was obvious to me my life were
revolving around music from day one
and my biggest hobby my biggest passion
was every cent i ever made
as a teenager working was to run
to the local record store in tel aviv
and
buy the new lp and come home and smell
the vinyl
because it was always a gorgeous smell i
learned english by
reading the lyrics of my favorite albums
where it becomes more complicated is uh
as i'm growing up my father who's a
big figure in the israeli defense
industry
of of the good old age uh he insisted on
me
not going into music because according
to him
a holocaust survivor music cannot be a
profession
um and i listened to him up to a point
i left the army i went to new york i uh
was fortunate enough to be admitted to
nyu stern school of business
and i met my wife there yuri i'm
mentioning her because she's a
probably the biggest teacher i have on
my journey she's a
yuri is not a russian man it's a
japanese lady
in this case um
and after three i i graduated three
years into
uh my first uh my my
mba sorry my ba at night
i used to go and study at the iar
in this institute of audio research down
university place in the village
wow because i didn't want to neglect my
musical
ambitions so i was doing business in the
morning and i went to this
great school at night to learn
sound engineering amazing years down in
the village
you can only imagine how much music and
culture is there
early 90s and then i went back to israel
worked in a record the biggest record
company in israel
i was in charge of bmg catalog in israel
bmg back then
is one of the five majors wow
obviously it went well i was uh very
flattered when bmg
offered me a position in the
headquarters european headquarters back
in 95.
and i was fortunate enough to get there
to munich and spend two years there
right after the prestroicca end of 80s
beginning of the 90s where
basically the music industry global
music industry is learning to cope with
eastern europe wow and i was one of the
people who were in charge of building a
bridge between the eastern european
territories i did a r and marketing
with them and bridging to western europe
and trying to create a common language
it was incredible i was waking up every
morning meeting the
legends of my childhood i was working
with annie lenox on a tour global tour
incredible and then harvard mba
again amazing compliment to be admitted
to that school
boston two years and all throughout i'm
constantly worried about losing my grip
on the music business
once i graduated from harvard uh it was
apparent to me that it's either staying
with bmg north america um
in becoming one of uh
the strategic people of this huge major
uh company bertelsmann music group a
dream for any strategist in the music
industry
right or the dream or
uh giving up on a huge salary
coming back to israel after spending
almost 10 years overseas
and uh the reason i came back and maybe
this is the
the the point of it all i i realized
that if i'm not in israel where i was
born
and raised i wouldn't be able to be
hands-on on the music
i would be forever stuck quote-unquote
in a great job with great salary
uh strategy and board meetings but the
music
was the point the music was the trigger
and i i just couldn't see myself
looking forward without uh without being
hands-on involved with the music and so
what happened
as of 98 i came back to israel and
i realized as i was being hired back
into the local industry
i realized that i'm one of the few who
is fortunate enough to be able to
um work with a musical endeavor
or or startup starting with the
composition
with the studio with the arrangements
with the production with the sound
the experience the real
making of the song wow but being able to
also
strategize how this song or album
or artist or career are gonna be rolled
into the market strategy included
being involved in every detail
commercial detail the pricing of a
ticket in the box office
all the way to the poster or the art of
the cover of the album
an amazing experience because then you
realize you can be not only the director
of the film
or the photographer but also the
producer and the
strategy behind and so it's a 360 really
experience
and music became a religion uh finally
and truthfully
i was able to realize all my knowledge
all the stuff that i've acquired in new
york and boston and over the years and
internationally and locally in japan and
germany and america and israel
and and then the projects uh yeah it
turned well
i'm very fortunate to have worked with
the biggest
talents that israel can produce it's
amazing
it's an amazing journey i'm very
fortunate and very lucky in it
i have to tell you i i did i spoke to a
lot of people here
people that did really amazing things
the authenticity
i believe you so much when you talk
about
bridging your passions together taking a
non-trivial path
foregoing the dream that people will
work their whole life to achieve
to sort of come back down to earth
to the local scene israel nine million
people he was six
or five back then i think right
absolutely not a huge music industry no
not at all not a professional one even
yet
you and i'm hearing you say i i'm lucky
to have been able to make that choice
this is uh not something that i believe
nowadays that i chose this is something
that chose me
there was no going against that internal
flame the urge the passion
it's it's bordering craziness at times
you cannot
not do it in that way i think i was
lucky
because i understand from many
colleagues of mine
that i lost some time with career
choices and and you know
how to progress with life and what
should i do next there was no question
with me
and that's why i was fortunate the
calling was such a
strong inner voice that every time i
deviated from it
too far wow i i had to go back and zero
in on on what it is that i started doing
and what it is i want to do with my life
and it was so obvious and it was just a
matter of staying on track
never knowing what's coming next but
obviously if you're answering your call
the universe does listen i i i know it
sounds like a big cliche but that's my
personal journey and and i'm that's what
i'm grateful for
now gotti i want to pick your brain soon
about your insights
into the music industry yeah and in
order to do that
truthfully i really want to ask about
your experience in 2006 and
and how that provides some perspective
that
you mentioned would be very very
difficult to to achieve without
yeah um january
2006 was the
peak time of uh my uh musical
success here in the local market with
the project of idan raikhal
with uh sheri maimon and the eurovision
with every leader with the light partner
with with
with heroes of my chat i was involved
with many projects
i felt like i'm taking too much on
two three months before what i'm about
to say
i already felt something is wrong wow
again that inner voice that inner
compass which should be listened to
very much it's a strong advice if you
know and you hear your inner voice
talking
better be tuned into it um
i i unfortunately was involved with a
terrible car accident
january 2006 it was entirely my fault
my eyes weren't on the road as i was
driving i was probably
changing cds listening to demos or a
phone call came in and i was busy
picking it up
the next thing i know i am put into an
ambulance
that's when i woke up i have no idea of
how long i was
unconscious but i woke up and i knew and
i'm telling you honestly
again that inner voice i knew as i'm
being put into the ambulance that first
a
my situation is severe is bad
uh b i'm gonna be
totally fine i knew that as i was
placed in the ambulance um
insights from a crack crashing event
like that
are numerous first of all it's a a big
crisis is a big gift a big crisis is
when
somebody puts a fork in the wheel
and you're forced to stop
really stop the corona is yet another
crisis that forced
the human race to stop and i realized
maybe the hardest thing for humans
to do is to stop but the accident 2006
and six forced me the hyperactive guy
who's now busy realizing all his dreams
to stop for six months of rehabilitation
and physical rehabilitation
it forced me to stop
and and look inside and look at all
those times that my wife was saying
please look at the road and i was too
arrogant to listen
but deeper than that i was forced to
stop and
and examine
the hard disk here the hard disk here
was full of ego because
that was the culmination of six years of
like i said being involved with many of
these successful musical projects
and music being my hobby and my passion
in my profession
when you're experiencing so much success
over such a short period of time it you
you
start thinking maybe it's your doing
maybe it's what your your touch your
instinct
your strategy and i think the only way
to dismantle this ticking bomb and this
mega ego who's sitting there thinking
that it's all he's doing
was to have this car accident happen i i
don't think a smaller lesson would have
helped
i found myself immediately after the
accident reading
books that never before were
even close to being in my vicinity or
even interesting remotely interesting to
me it went from
buddhism to indian advaita
to quantum physics to interpersonal
psychology
and i don't remember how i ended up
reading
and and and listening to these podcasts
and courses
audio courses it it was just an amok
run led by a stronger force
sorry it sounds spiritual but it's not
what i'm hearing you though
and i'm drawing a thread from you before
because you didn't change as a person
what i'm hearing you is you perhaps at
the end there's a big change but i'm
hearing you took the same intellectual
curiosity
right and the same ambition to learn and
understand
right only this time the energy was of
directed internally exactly exactly the
same passion
the same drive but now the other
direction
absolutely you take the camera which is
always facing the outside world
and you're saying once and for all
having experienced such a crisis
and such a big blow and
the highs of the world the highs of the
highs
you turned the camera and now you're
saying okay i missed
the plot wow i thought i'm in control
obviously i ain't
i thought i know obviously i don't
i thought it was all about me obviously
it is not
i've got to undo me
and this is not a realization that comes
all of a sudden at one time
and you're you know floating on the
cloud it's a process that is ongoing
now as we speak for 15 years um
and the internal change and the internal
mechanisms that you're so caught up with
or basically a victim of all of a sudden
are being unraveled one thread at a time
until you can look at the inside
mechanism at your
own hard disk parallelly to being in
tune with what's happening
around you and outside and if you can
balance the two
then it's a whole new world we met for
the first time
a week and a half ago right till i
bought nurse concert
one of the first concerts in israel in
the world post coven
right and i saw you standing behind the
audience
right very close to the song very close
but behind the audience from far right
one of the farthest people from the show
right you're smiling i had a chance to
come up
through a mutual friend and thank you
for the gift that that you and eli
and alvarez gave me and i was thinking
about that smile
and your contentness for a long time
and and your distance from the actual
show
i would imagine that you would be right
backstage
right next to you like two meters away
you were
back why that's a great question thank
you for giving me a chance to think
about it um
first of all i'm very close to the sound
uh board which is the brain of what's
going on on stage
in case there is anything wrong or some
tweaking that has to be done
me being the director of the show or the
director of the movie i'm very close
and uh one whisper to the sound engineer
and things are
balanced again so that's one reason the
second reason is ah
that's a gorgeous thing i'm i'm a very
firm believer of the yin and yang i
think you can
only understand something thoroughly if
you see
both sides of the story or the problem
or the person
or the case with the music show
for me of course god is in the details
as we say
and every note in every instrument and
every part and every
word being sung by the lead singers
those are the details
but having been with the live partner
for 15 years and knowing
every single detail every single bar
every single note in that production
my duty as far as i understand it is to
zoom out so i can also
see the whole experience that we're
trying
to put up as a show and to
have our audience go through we have to
be
in touch with the overall experience and
not just be
bogged down with the details nitty
gritty details
when the show is on when the audience is
there
there is an energy a circle of energy
that has to start from the artist on
stage
go out to you as an audience and come
back to the artists that are on the
stage
if this circle is not complete if it's
broken
due to some and it's always energy we're
dealing with music music is pure energy
if the sound is not right if the
performance is not right if the audience
is bored and i see it immediately i feel
it
wow then you have to tweak it and and
look at it
as a whole and the details the details
we've
taken care of when we were recording the
songs or we were rehearsing the songs
when we're
there's time for details and there's
time for hole for me
and i i keep shifting from being up
close and personal to zooming out like i
keep shifting from the inner
mechanisms of the ego to the outside
world where i have to interact
that's being married to a japanese lady
here it is for you
in a nutshell i i i can't even express
how how much fun i'm having
and uh how inspiring all this this is
it's amazing
zooming out a little bit more you've
been in this industry for a long time
yeah you've seen changes
yeah i heard today a talk you gave at
limon
i believe in their culminating event in
and you were speaking to the new
upcoming artists
that are going to emerge into this
industry
and you talked to them to their brain
and their heart
from your deep experience share with me
a little bit how you perceive
you know the ever-changing world with
the music industry specifically
so the music industry was there at the
forefront of the new digital revolution
may i remind everybody who's watching
that we're talking about napster
98 napster was a file sharing program
um the record companies were suing
users of napster wow back then
and uh i i'm mentioning that because
uh 1998 the world is not yet surfing the
internet as a default we're not there
yet doing shopping online
we're not yet we don't have a zoom the
this world is still very much
in in its infancy stages and
and the record business is already
challenged
with a huge problem which is how
to get over the fact that our product
the music industry's product is so
light so sexy so immediate
so common so simple that you can
absolutely
take it from its rightful owners and
just send it out on the internet and
millions of people are enjoying it for
free
now do you allow it because it's a new
day and age
or is the right owner or the recording
owner you
immediately uh grab your whatever you
can
and try to create recreate the stability
that you've known
this was the mistake that the music
industry was making back then
they decided to they decided to to
attach themselves to the old
system the old formula the old
structures
not paying enough attention to the fact
that their
biggest fans the users the customers
are now saying clearly out loud
the way we're going to consume your
product has changed
and it's going to remain like that
forever
we're not going to buy cds anymore we're
not going to be told what to listen to
when
and how we're going to listen to music
on the fly wherever we are
on demand all the time
and that was it a new era was dawning
and the music industry
and and it's known it's there are books
written all over it
all about it it's the music industry was
uh
was dealing with this enormous challenge
in a very crooked way
it you cannot blame them because it's
very hard to be
in the eye of the storm and have the
perspective already in real time
to change your ways a car accident did
it for me
but that too starts a process
happening it's not that you get the all
the answers immediately
so it took a while for the music
industry to adjust
here's the point the user the user the
user
that's where your focus should be your
customer your user
the people you're trying to create the
experience for the audience
that's where your your attention should
be and the patterns of
consuming music consumption the way we
listen to music nowadays
is completely different i'll throw some
numbers at you every day
there are 60 to 80 000 songs
a day being uploaded to the internet
which means it's half a million new
tracks
a week two million songs a month
are being uploaded to the internet every
month and this number is rising and
rising two million songs
no one no matter how big a music fan you
are
no one can find his way or her way
around two
million songs not to mention the fact
that this is parallel to
a surplus of of videos
and podcasts and and
stories and visuals and and still still
pictures and content
which means that all barriers
are gone every
household if there is a curious child
there with a computer at hand
is a potential uh recording studio
one of the lines that you that you set
to to the students
when you drive home from le mans today
you look out look at the windows
and look out the window of your car and
look at all the apartments you're
driving by each of those is the
potential each of those is a potential
recording studio
now let's talk about what what changed
in the consumer's
pattern of consumption because there's
so much of it
even if i am the biggest music fan
because i'm
flooded with music 24 7 two things are
happening
one is i become indifferent
it's very hard to move me it's very hard
to
get to me because i'm constantly
bombarded with music
that creates indifference how do you
tackle that indifference you have to
raise the bar the experience
that you want to put your listener
through
has to change okay
another thing is happening the way we
interface with music
nowadays is while all of us
are busy or deliver a
short attention span shorter than ever
the human race is going through
something and
interfacing with the world is changing
and so the songs are changing
look carefully and you'll see that many
tracks nowadays start with the chorus
and not with the verse like the classic
model immediate gratification is
because here is another data for you in
12 seconds and this is an official data
point
it takes the average music fan 12
seconds to decide whether you stick with
the song
or you go to the next wow
12 seconds is nothing no wonder
the songs became shorter it used to be
three and four minutes in the 80s and
90s it's now down to 2
30. this is a physical change of how we
produce music
and also it's very clear to us the music
makers
that we have practically 12 seconds
to convince you or else
skip to the next track so here's a
question for you
what does that do to the the creativity
to how what does that do to you as an
artist you're saying
i'm a musician i have the it's a part of
my soul
right i'm not doing this for you know
i'm doing this because i need to
right but now instead of i listen to
american pie don mclean
seven and a half minutes right oh
bohemian rhapsody six minutes
now what do we do how do we create it
does
affect the way music is being written
first and foremost
uh my experience with working with young
generations of musicians
no longer do you finish working on a
song
at home and you bring a whole piece to
the studio to the studio to be produced
this is the always nowadays we're
sitting in the studio and we're creating
as we go somebody is writing a verse
somebody is uh playing around with some
beats
somebody's doodling on the keyboards to
come up with the melody
some other guy will say hey listen guys
i have an idea why don't you try a
fiddle
all people who are present in the studio
during this process are part of the
creative
process it's no longer what bob dylan
used to do which is sitting and sit at
home write the
lyrics and play the guitar and come up
come into the studio with the finished
product
this is how things are changed also i i
have to reiterate this
people today are not
going to listen to music
with the same amount of concentration
as they used to it's there all the time
coming from speakers on the streets in
restaurants
in hotels in airplanes when you watch a
clip on youtube instagram picture there
is
constantly content
composing your experience in your life
there's a soundtrack to your life
this is different than the way it used
to be whereas where if you wanted to
listen to music
you would turn on the radio or you would
clear some time
and sit with your earphones and listen
to your favorite vinyl
that's no longer the case it's on the
fly on the go
all the time it's a different experience
we have to understand what it means to
have a different experience
i am i'm getting anxious just by
thinking of how many
questions i have for you diving all
different directions so i'm already
booking you for another episode because
i we didn't even begin to scratch the
surface
and i'm so honored that you're giving me
this time thank you it's my pleasure and
you give me a chance to reflect it's i'm
i'm beyond thrilled for this
thank you so much i have a few questions
about you yeah
about gotti again the least interesting
thing yeah
take me back to middle school what
fascinated you as a kid what subject in
school
music music music and then some music
here throughout your career a role model
some some inspiration
well there are artists that i um
i immediately if i will play a track by
a few selected artists
i would probably immediately
unconditionally start crying
my family is always laughing at me so
instead of mentioning now 10 or 20
artists or vocalists or composers
i'll just mention a few artists but a
big inspiration during the latter 15
years
is jideo krishnamurti
i think the greatest teacher and
philosopher and writer of the 20th
century
wrote many books there are some
centers of um teaching that are
nowadays opening in england and in uh
california the guy uh was
phenomenal and in his ability to look at
his own
brain hard disc as i call it and and
internal mechanisms
and be able to teach this is very hard
topic to talk about because words are
standing
in between you and the understanding and
yet the only way to explain is with
words
the one who managed to write the best
books about this topic
in my eyes is jideon krishna modi he
really lays it out for you if you want
to follow the path
and he's the first writer who said it's
a pathless path
and yet he wrote the books so it's an
incredible
incredible um inspiration
judo krishnamurti yeah um first thing
i'm doing after this
please and if i were to ask you
or both anybody that you worked with
anybody that knows you or yourself who's
gadi
who's got it today 2021.
candy today is the sum total of his uh
conditionings from the israeli culture
and the jewish religion
and life international life
and relationship with jury and uh
everything 51 years are actually without
realizing it are very much a part of how
i interface with the world
now right now i'm with you you're asking
what is god they got this the
entire hard disk um
and gaddy should be allowed to
continue to unfold without any
interruption
and i'm i learned not to interrupt
that's a very hard thing to do as a
father
not to interrupt your kids and as a
person not to interrupt god
this inner voice is sacred to me however
the true the true you or the true
each and every one of us is is not
limited to the
mind-body organism that i can say for
sure there is a bigger thing going on
and let's stop there because this is not
a
spirituality course so
but human race is about to experience a
big shift in consciousness
it's happening as we speak the digital
global village
is a big big part of it a big step
forward
thank you very much for listening and
for asking these wonderful questions
thank you
you